[Music]
adam is with us in toronto hey adam
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing dave good man what's
up
oh nothing no i shouldn't say nothing
quite a bit but just a little bit of a
recap back in 2016 my wife and i did as
you say stupid with zeros on the end of
it
uh spent a lot and 2017 paid off about
65 000 bucks of debt in 11 months
and i never did end up getting down for
a debt-free screen but anyway
um fast forward now in the last i guess
a couple years colbert has kind of
destroyed my industry that i'm a pilot
and in canada here it really took a bad
hit it's just kind of recovering now and
uh so with the stress that that kind of
brought about which brought some
marriage issues along with it and uh
life is in a really uh bad spot right
now i guess we both kind of are
and um
is not sure if she wants to work on the
marriage or what she wants to do and
we're kind of in this stalemate but in
the resulting
aftermath is that she's decided that
she's going to spend
however she wants to spend and kind of
go back to you know she's saying we make
too much money there's no way i should
have to have any restraint and so
uh kind of spending about oh i'd say
about two thousand dollars a month over
what we make
and as a result of kind of depleted our
emergency fund almost down to nothing
she signed up for an elective surgery to
the tune of about ten thousand dollars
and one kind of questions on the timing
of it she just said well
i'm either either we fund it somehow
through us or i'm just gonna look at my
whole credit card do it myself
and uh and so
but every time i bring up finances to
her to uh to talk about it uh she says
you're obsessed with money you've got to
stop being so obsessed i'm trying to
just bring her to the reality that we're
spending more than we make and we're
kind of gradually bankrupting the family
you know it's got four young children
and trying to you know put money aside
for them as well and retirement now that
we're kind of both kind of getting back
on our feet we do make good money but
the reality is we're just spending way
too much and she has no desire to even
talk about it she'll still involve me
every time i try to bring it up and i'm
worried that i'm going to tip her over
the edge in the marriage if i talk too
much about finances but if i you're my
marriage
well that's the thing if i i feel like
i'm kind of giving the drunk a drink you
didn't hear me
you didn't hear me
your marriage is already gone
yeah well i mean she does give
indications that she doesn't want to
make it worse no she does that no she
does not right no no no no she doesn't
people that do the things and say the
things that she's doing have no desire
for this marriage to continue
yeah when you say things like if you
don't go if you don't uh
pay for this ten thousand dollar i'm
just gonna put it on a credit card screw
you you don't have a vote
this is not a marriage this is not
someone that has a marriage anymore that
wants to work at all
and so what i would do if i were in your
shoes is the two of you would say i'm
going to go see a marriage counselor
and it's either going to be with you on
how we learn to get back on the same
page and we have a future together
that's going to include us both being
grown-ups um and if you want to go with
that that's fine if not the marriage
counselor is going to instruct me on how
to bring this marriage to an end
yeah we have done some counseling and it
did have
trying to get her to come back to it is
the hard part and she's very reluctant
yeah you're begging her to do stuff then
she you know and she has no desire she's
obstinate she's angry and she's done
she's done the marriage is over
uh i mean it's tough to say that because
she does see that she still does she
wants she's lying what she says is not
what she's doing and so that's the
problem yeah
and again people that want their
marriage to work do not behave the way
that she is behaving
yes i would agree okay
so she's lying
yes
elective surgery for ten thousand
dollars when you're broke and the
family's in financial stress
that's so selfish and asinine i can't
even put words to it yeah i know that's
that's kind of my thought too
it just is it's a fact it's not an
opinion
it's that that is her screaming in your
face that she's
done yeah
yeah i know i don't really like to think
of it that way obviously because it's
not a nice outcome for anybody and this
is this mess and i think
i'm not sure you did it i think you're
just the one that's going to admit it
yeah now i would agree with you going
back a couple months that she was done
and however she's had some influential
people in her life in the last months or
two that have helped bring her around
her attitude has changed well then that
would involve you guys getting in a good
getting with a good marriage counselor
immediately yes but then she needs to
turn into action
yes and she has admitted that that is an
option i i did confront her about it
about a couple weeks ago and she has i
said this is what i want to do i had
some referrals for focus on the family
and she said
yes that is an option and so i'm just
kind of trying to
not push her because she doesn't know i
am going to pressure no you don't
understand
it's time to push her it's time to push
you
the house is on fire
it's burning down around you get out of
the house
push somebody
yeah i am i definitely am i'm bringing
stuff up fairly regularly but you know
kind of teetering on the edge of not
wanting to push her over one side to get
her
her emotional side to engage i want to
honey what you think is being nice is
not nice
you think you're you think you can beg
and be sweet and cause this to happen
and it's i'm not asking you to be mean
to her but you're acting like that you
can beg her into wanting to do this she
has to stand up square her shoulders and
say i'm going to re-engage in this
marriage and re-engage as two adults on
how to run our household and she has to
do that under the heading of a therapist
and the two of you learn to work
together again you cannot expect her to
behave
yes i agree with that totally it's you
know i i can't change her she has to
decide to do it it's a matter of you
know we're trying to get you know
obviously lots of prayer and other
friends of influence you have to get
around her absolutely change her heart
absolutely what dave's saying is this is
an emergency i'm just saying
you guys need to be sitting with a
counselor
and and she needs to be going and if
she's not going
then we need to know what that we need
to admit what that says
okay but all this there is not a
financial technique that's a problem
here
the financial problems in the financial
spending are all about her obstinance
and you trying to talk talk your way
around it to where it's all somehow okay
it's not okay
it's not okay
it doesn't work that way and so if uh
whitney uh decided to start just start
telling george what she was gonna do
george would have a thing have a thing
you know here's what we're gonna do i
don't tell sharon what to do shane tell
me what to do we sit down we talk about
like two adults we devise a plan on how
we're gonna do the calendar how we're
gonna do the budget how we're gonna live
our life we work together towards common
goals this is called a quality
relationship
in your marriage uh but when people
start throwing it around they're just
like i'm gonna do whatever i want to do
and they get the all head bobbin thing
going and you shouldn't have got married
then it's you know you you've got a mess
on your hands and you've got to go back
and try to try to learn how to be
married and that takes both people and
you can't beg someone to behave you
cannot control someone else's behavior
your behavior is the only thing you can
control
and you put in a situation to go if you
do this then you're choosing to opt out
if you do this you're choosing to opt in
but i can't make you choose that's the
only thing you can do is present options
to her but this idea of i'm going to let
her be go run our family and bankrupt us
so that by being nice and letting her do
stupid butt stuff that's going to ruin
our family then that and causes her to
go to counseling that's that's a that's
a false narrative that doesn't work
that's if the auspices for her going to
counseling is so that is because she got
bribed
by you you're putting up with a bunch of
crap then that no that is not how you
start rebuilding this thing
so now you guys need you desperately
both of you need to sit in the
counseling counselor's room immediately
or you're not going to make it and the
spending stuff is just i'm not we're not
going i'm not going along with it
and if you don't like it i'm just part
of what we can talk to the counselor
about or it's part of what we can talk
to the divorce judge about one of the
two it's one of the two but i'm not
going along with this
because it's not right and i'm not
suggesting you leave today i'm
suggesting that the two of you get into
the counselor's office
four years ago but right now for sure
it's only best option best time to plant
an oak tree ten years ago next best time
is today oh yeah that's a great quote
she sees him as basically a doormat at
this point because she knows well i'm
just gonna do what i want he's not going
to tell me off yeah he's not going to
have the conflict you have to stop being
scared that you're going to cause the
marriage to end by
pushing by pushing the marriage to
succeed
that's that that's
that is not going to work it's not going
to work you're going to end up nowhere
but bankruptcy court and divorce court
at the same time
oh man sorry so sorry what a horrible
thing you're going through i sure hope
she comes around i hope the two of you
get in counseling and i hope it saves
your marriage but you know you
participating in crazy
is not going to make crazy go away